Direct variation means that two amounts are related such that if one increases,
the other increases. Or, if one decreases, the other decreases as well. This
makes sense in terms of working for an hourly wage and earning money. If you
work less hours, you earn less money. The second type of variation is inverse
variation. If you work more hours, the amount of free time that you would have
would decrease. Notice here, one quantity is increasing but the other one would
be Decreasing. We could also have the relationship reversed, we could work less
hours, which means we would have more free time. In the rest of this lesson
we're going to use our knowledge of direct variation and inverse variation to
solve some problems. But before we get there, let's see if you understand the
difference between the two.